good morning Hank it's Friday I know I
promised I wasn't gonna film blog
Brothers videos in my fancy studio but
it's so fancy and there's a trampoline
in here and my chair and a globe and I'm
so happy today I want to talk about
banking typically I want to deliver the
quarterly report for the Bank of
nerdfighteria a bank that spans the
entire wait for it globe so Hank allow
me to pontificate from my asymmetrical
throne we all know that finance is
influenced by the political events of
the day like the promised resignation of
national embarrassment Silvio Berlusconi
what he's not that's not his job title
its Prime Minister reale that doesn't
seem likely Berlusconi's resignation
hasn't calmed the markets at all and
there is still great fear that in Europe
there will be bank runs and credit
crunches and just a nightmare not only
for Europe but for the entire world
meanwhile at the bank of nerdfighteria
things have never been better
Hank the Bank of nerdfighteria like Toby
Turner has two arms I guess also other
people it's just Toby's been on my mind
a lot lately I love you Toby hey Kai
probably thought to pick a Toby job for
at least three videos there's the
lending arm and the giving arm most
banks have a taking arm but we decided
to dispense with that one so let's begin
with the giving arm also known as the
foundation to decrease worldsuck
thanks to t-shirt and game sales and
your reprehensible goatee nerdfighters
have now donated more than four thousand
dollars to the foundation to decrease
worldsuck Hank off topic but I hate your
goatee and I can't believe I have to
live with it for another 20 days I think
your goatee looks like some distant
descendant of a Tribble attacked your
face and frankly as long as it is on
your face I could not in good faith call
you my brother because no brother of
mine would ever have such horrible
facial that's not fair come on okay all
right you're still my brother
nerdfighters Hank and I are gonna match
your donations for the first $10,000
which means that we have already raised
more than $8,000 that will be
distributed through the project for
awesome giving arm is rocking out but
the lending arm is doing even better
across six continents our Antarctica but
you don't have any developing world
entrepreneurs nerdfighters have loaned
more than $75,000 through kiva.org so
like I recently loan money to Edith in
El Salvador she has a book store that
also sells candy note to self start a
book store that also sells candy and she
needed money in order to refurbish our
bookstore and also buy new stock
I loaned her that money she paid me back
everyone who lives happily ever after
she reported back to me that her
business is growing which was awesome of
her Thank You Edith I was also recently
paid back by her yama an accountant
living in Lebanon whose name I probably
just mispronounced she renovated her
office with the money I loaned her and
reports that her income has since gone
way up so yay in fact I've now made more
than 70 loans through kiva.org and I
have never not been paid back said the
novelist using a double negative by the
waying for anyone who doesn't know
kiva.org is a website that allows anyone
to make loans to entrepreneurs in the
developing world and they almost always
pay you back so it's like charity except
it's free there's a link in the
doobly-doo if you want to join the
nerdfighters group and contribute to the
lending arm of our bank cut anyway you
can learn a lot about nerdfighteria from
looking at the graphs of our loans for
instance that we like food and that we
prefer to give loans to ladies perhaps
because we are primarily ladies it looks
like a lady pac-man eating two dudes
we're remarkably good about geographic
distribution but our two favorite
countries start with pea Peru and the
Philippines so apparently we're people
and finally Hank no quarterly report
would be complete without talk of growth
the giving arm of the Bank of
nerdfighteria has grown infinite percent
from zero to over 8,000 can we just give
an extra thousand bucks and so I can say
it's over 9000 and the lending arm over
at kiva.org has grown by more than two
hundred thirty-four percent this quarter
not bad nerdfighters if you want to join
either arm of the Bank of nerdfighteria
there are links in the doobly-doo to
fight worldsuck org and our Kiva group
and Hank thank you for being so
committed to reducing world suck that
you're willing to endanger your marriage
and Sully your face don't forget to be
awesome I will see you on Monday